for under 10 years old how excited are
you and Blake you'd have to be a
to do this four times if you didn't like
it Blake Lively and Ryan Reynolds
celebrating a new bundle of joy have you
figured it all out yet the parenting
thing you could ask me that in 90 years
and I'm gonna say you know yeah this is
baby number four yeah it's gonna be a
nuts but we're very excited and right on
the heels of their 10th wedding
anniversary we're lucky you know that's
that's amazing in Hollywood years that's
like 145 years well we like each other
it's a good foundation for any
relationship leading up to the big day
Ryan received the American Cinema Tech
award and Blake was glowing as she
stepped out to support her hubby it's
very different getting dressed with a
watermelon as a stomach Blake even hit
the stage to say Ryan creates magic in
his work but man oh man does he create
Magic in his real life when your sister
started dating Ryan I would imagine you
have to get the seal of approval from
your sis was it an easy yes for you 100
yes he's so wonderful he's a wonderful
father wonderful brother incredible
actor Pokemon in general is like catnip
to children
the guy he's adorable you're adorable
yep I'm doing it I'm in I need more of
that validation for my child
[Music]
following their firstborn the actors
opened up to E.T about how much they
love their new roles as Mom and Dad do
you now that your mom do you take like
looks and keep them and maybe you want
to pass them on oh yeah I've done it
always like since I've been 16 I'm like
my child will love this piece from
Forever 21 one day that's just like
falling apart that they're never gonna
want you look at this little face you
think I'm only gonna know this person
for you know hopefully 50 55 years you
know it doesn't suddenly it doesn't seem
like a long time and fast forward to
2021 that perspective LED Ryan to push
pause on his career for a bit it's
really about getting some quality time
with my kids before they're uh before
their you know teenagers who loathe me
and as Ryan told us he's got no regrets
I took a year off I just love being home
with my family and you know taking the
kids to school I have so many other
aspects in my life that keep me busy and
it seems like you've been busy with the
friends friendship bracelets too oh yeah
my daughters love to love to make Daddy
bracelets they're probably tracking
devices actually now that I think about
it following them yes
[Music]
thank you